the eyes to the right
484 the nose to the left
76 the eyes to the right
76 so the eyes have it the
eyes have it unlock
we now come to motion number four on
coronavirus act 20 20 one-year status
report and i call
secretary matt so there we are sam 484
76 uh i won't pretend it's my math
i've just been told my ear 408 is the
uh majority so comfortable as you were
saying
that's right um it will be absolutely
critical to look at
who the votes against uh ended up being
uh
cast by uh you'll have the 11 liberal
democrats we expect roughly around 20
labor
and then um so potentially in the region
of 40 conservative mps actually voting
against
uh the prime minister in this measure
um now that's clearly nowhere near uh
enough to carry
um but it's interesting that um the
debate in the house of commons
has almost always been a process of
individuals uh who think that lockdown
measures are too tough
too draconian too hard rather than being
a big
caucus in uh in the commons of people
who think that the lockdown isn't tough
enough that there need to be more
measures
uh and uh frequently mps have been
campaigning to lift restrictions at a
point where other parliaments like the
scottish parliament or the welsh
parliament
have been cracking down more so clearly
the instinct in the parliament
in in this parliament the 2019 election
parliament
that we have in place at the moment is
not to have um tougher rules than we
could possibly avoid and i think we saw
that
uh with that vote again today